The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: Good
evening, people.
We continue our
discussion of neorealism
by looking closely tonight
at one classic instance
of the neorealist
movement, the single most
famous film from that
school, Bicycle Thieves.
Before I turn to talking a
bit about aspects of Bicycle
Thieves itself, which
I hope will frame
your viewing in a way that
will help you get a lot out
of the first
viewing of the film,
I want to say a few words
about Vittorio De Sica himself.
I mentioned this afternoon
that the neorealist movement,
although it was
immensely influential
and continues to be influential,
in fact, on realist filmmakers
and on documentarians, and it
was especially in its earliest
phases, hailed globally as
a very remarkable movement,
it incited criticism almost
from the beginning inside Italy.
And I suggested
it this afternoon
that some complaints
against movie
essentially came from
conservative forces
in the society that felt
that the portrait of decay
and breakdown and
dislocation that
was at the center of neorealist
films-- after all, they
were about the
contemporary world
and about the broken universe,
the broken planet, at least
a broken Europe that we
encountered after the war.
There were many kinds of
conservatives in Italy
who felt that it promulgated a
bad image for the society, that
made investment more difficult,
that it was a kind of downer.
And this criticism
was very powerful.
But what really
undermined the movement
in terms of getting financing,
the reason that the movement
sort of ended after
about the time Umberto
D, the last of the
truly neorealist films
that De Sica made,
was produced in 1952.
It's life was very, very brief.
Many people would say that
was the end of neorealism
although there are
some films that
come after that have neorealist
dimensions and elements in them
including some by Fellini.
Still the idea that the
movement had a very short life
despite its immense influences
it is an accurate one.
But what I had left
out this afternoon
is an important
qualification or addition
which is that the films
also incited criticism
from the left.
When you see Bicycle
Thieves you'll
see why that might
be a surprising fact,
because the
sympathies of the film
are so totally on the side
of the underprivileged
and the underclasses
of the culture.
It's difficult from our
contemporary vantage point
to see what would've
offended leftists.
But there was a very
vigorous and theoretically
sophisticated communist
movement in Italy in this period
as there continues to
be today in some degree.
And many people on the
left, especially communists,
but socialists as
well, also complained
about neorealist films.
In particular about
De Sica's films
because their
complaint was not that
the difficulties of the
World War were exposed.
They were perfectly
happy with that.
But they were angry
that there wasn't
a program for renovation.
What they were
really angry about
was that there wasn't a Marxist
or a socialist program built
into the films.
And it's always struck me as a
very revealing and interesting
fact about the movement that
it couldn't satisfy either left
or right, even though
these films are
among the most powerful
and compassionate films
about the lives of ordinary--
not just ordinary people,
but people without power,
of people without control
over their lives that
have ever been made.
So it's a curious fact.
It bothered De Sica
all his life that he
seemed unable to
please either side
in that political argument.
And at one point in an
interview he said something--
if I could find my notes,
I'd like to quote to you.
He said in response
to a question
that asked him why do
you think the socialists
and the communists were
somewhat-- or at least
some socialists, so
remember Zavattini
was a socialist, so he
collaborated deeply and loved
De Sica and collaborated with
him on his most important film.
So I don't mean that all
socialists thought ill
of neorealism.
They did not.
But some did and certainly
people on the far left
definitely did.
And here was De Sica's
response to why-- he expressed
disappointment about this.
But his response really
in a way is a critique
of the programmatic
demands that these people
were making on his films.
He said, "My films are a
struggle against the absence
of human solidarity."
You should think
about this quotation
as you're watching tonight's
film because as you'll
see in the film, the official
institutions of the society
seem to have broken
down or at least
to have become not effective.
They're overburdened.
They're somewhat indifferent.
It's mostly that
there overburdened,
that the problems
of the society are
too great for the
institutional structures that
are in place to
handle the problems.
But in any case as
you're watching the film,
I think you'll notice
not only that clearly
this breakdown of
institutions are
very-- that we
might expect to be
helpful to Ricci in his quest.
But what we will
also discover is
that there are other
forms of solidarity
that emerge in the film.
One of them is the solidarity
of husband and wife.
Another is the solidarity
very much tested in the film.
It's the great central theme
of the film, the solidarity
of father and son.
And then there's
also the solidarity
of what we might call
neighbors or neighborhoods.
And you'll see how
that element works
toward the end of the film in
its remarkable and surprising
conclusion.
Now here's the quotation.
"My films are a struggle
against the absence
of human solidarity against
the indifference of society
towards suffering.
They are a word in favor of
the poor and the unhappy."
One reason I like the
statement is it so,
in a certain sense,
unsystematic.
It shows-- they seem to me
to be the words of an artist
not a political pamphleteer.
And they partly explain the
richness, the resonance,
what I've been calling the
multiplicity of Bicycle
Thieves.
There's a moment
in Bicycle Thieves
about which Andre Bazin has
written very beautifully.
The same critic
that was a champion
of French poetic realism and
of genre and of war of course
becomes one of the
great champions
of Italian neorealism.
He can see that the
Italian form of realism
is an extension and
elaboration and in some ways
a deepening of the
implications of poetic realism.
He's written brilliantly
about the neorealists
and especially about De Sica.
There's one place in the
film that he particularly
focuses on one of his essays.
It's-- I have to give away a
small part of the plot in order
to explain this but it
really won't trouble you
because the plot engine gets
going so early in the film that
it's hardly a surprise.
In fact, you really know
what's going to happen almost
from the opening
dialogue in the film
where people are arguing
about who has bicycles
and who does not.
The film is organized in a very
elegant, relatively simple way.
It covers essentially
three days of time.
The first day is the
day in which Ricci gets
the commission for the job.
And then goes with his wife
to get his bicycle out a hock.
And you'll see that
they have to go
through certain kinds of tricks
to find the money to do this.
And then once he has his
bicycle he goes to work.
On his first day of
work, guess what happens?
Someone guess who
hasn't seen the film.
What do you think
might get stolen?
OK, right.
His bicycle is stolen on
the first day of work.
Now the fact is
you're really not
surprised when it
happens because almost
from that first scene you're
aware that bicycles are
this incredibly precious
object in the world
and yet also incredibly common.
And that's part of why it's such
a resonant symbol in the film.
But there at the
center of the film,
the most fundamental and most
memorable parts of the film
involve what I'll call
sort of the third segment.
I don't know that the
segments are actually
equal in proportion
in terms of time.
I think the third
is the longer one.
But the third sequence
is the Odyssey
or the quest in which
Ricci and his young son
embark upon in order
to recover his bicycle.
So he spends the whole-- I think
he gets his job, gets his bike,
starts his job on Friday,
has as bike stolen on Friday.
Or maybe it's on Saturday.
But in any case, he then
gets his bike stolen.
He then asks for help
from various sources
and the following day
he spends the entire day
walking through the city of Rome
looking for the thief trying
to find his bike.
He actually finds
the thief as you'll
see in the grand
climax of the film.
Although the thief turns out to
be as miserable and at least as
much without prospects
as poor Ricci himself.
Something very
interesting happens
in that moment in the film
because your sympathies
shift in some way to
the thief in an odd way.
And you watch as
his neighborhood
gathers around the
thief to protect him
in certain respects.
So the heart of the
film is this search
that the father and the son
go on through the third day
of the plot looking
for the bicycle.
As the day wears on, the father
becomes more and more nervous,
more and more uneasy, more
and more filled with anxiety.
The bike seems to him the
solution to all difficulties.
And sometimes the
son slows them down
and there are scenes in
which the father becomes
annoyed or angry
with the son but I'm
getting a bit ahead of myself.
So I won't repeat this again.
But I'll come back to these
matters in the theme of fathers
and sons.
In any case there's a moment in
this Odyssey where the father
and son are engaged in
the search for the bicycle
when it's just after-- I think
it's exactly at the moment when
there's a gigantic
downpour, they're
caught in a terrible rainstorm.
I think in fact the
rainstorm caused this.
The boy has to pee very badly.
And so he interrupts
the quest to go and pee.
I mean he has- you have
to go, you have to go.
But the father is so upset
that the boy has slowed
him down that the slaps him.
And you get a sense that
it's maybe the first moment
that this man has
ever struck his son.
It's a tremendously
fraught moment.
This is how Bazin
talks about it.
And this is why I
mention this moment now.
It's a way of illustrating
this principle of texture
or openness to experience--
that's part of the De Sica's
vision of the world.
He is a socially
conscious director
but he's not a programmatic or
a politically preachy director.
So Bazin focuses on that moment
I've just described to you.
He says, the boy needs to pee.
A downpour interrupt the chase.
Then he says quote, "The
events are not necessarily
signs of something of
the truth of which we
are to be convinced.
They all carry
their own weight."
The rain, the need to pee,
the father's anger, right?
"They all carry
their own weight.
Their complete uniqueness.
They all have," Bazin
so finely, "They all
have that ambiguity that
characterizes any fact."
When a film is able to
capture that ambiguity that
characterizes any fact,
it's a work of art.
It can be programmatic
if it does that.
And in fact the
moment I'm describing
is really in some
sense, a version
of what I've been calling
the neorealist counter plot.
What constantly happens
in good neorealist films
and what happens again and
again the Bicycle Thief
is that the ongoing
quest for the bicycle
is retarded or interrupted
by various kinds of accident
disturbance, strange encounter.
So that the search
for the bicycle
becomes something
much larger than that
and every particular moment in
the film has, as Bazin says,
its own uniqueness,
its own-- you
don't feel that anything is in
the film to further the plot
or to illuminate the
character or to tell you
something about what political
attitudes you should have.
Although by the time you're
finished with the film
you do have a very
coherent sense
of how the society
is breaking down,
of how people are
sustaining themselves,
about how difficult life
is in postwar Italy.
You're aware of all
of these things.
And aware of them with a
concreteness and the clarity
that you wouldn't have if
you read an abstract essay.
You've seen them embodied in
a totally believable fiction.
But what gives the fiction
it's authority, what gives it
its power is precisely
that you don't
feel you're watching a sermon.
You don't feel you're
watching something
in which some political moralist
is beating you over the head
and telling you, oh you better
love this poor guy, you better.
And in fact as the film goes on,
one of the things you discover
is that there are nasty or
bad sides to poor Ricci.
We understand that he's driven
by economic anxiety that's
very deep and partly
and certainly mitigates
his behavior.
But he behaves crudely
and cruelly to his son,
never intending to.
Then of course there are moments
when he recovers and tries
to make up with his son.
I'll come back to
this in a moment.
So this passage from
Bazin also calls attention
to what I think of as a
signal feature in these films
and especially in
the Bicycle Thief,
that power that any
moment in the film
has to express a kind
of complete uniqueness,
the ambiguity that
characterizes reality itself.
Well, what I'd
like to briefly do
is give you a partial account,
a modest account of De Sica's
own career and then
say some things
about the Bicycle Thieves.
De Sica was a stage actor.
He gave regimental performances
when he served in the Army
in the first World War.
He became a stage hand right
after the war and an actor
in 1923.
He joined a theater company
in 1925, a touring company,
and he became a
tremendous success
in a series of performances.
In 1927 he appeared
on stage in Rome
in something called
[? Sabun ?] Reviews
and I think it involved
singing and dancing.
This was an unbelievable
success and turned him
into a kind of a matinee idle
or at least a theater icon.
He made his first film in that
same year in 1922 as an actor.
And his first success
came-- he continued
to act in films intermittently
for the next decade
but he didn't become a
recognizably serious film actor
until his first major
success in 1932.
Then for 10 years, he's a kind
of matinee idle Italian movies.
He made over 40
films in the period
as an actor between
1932 and 1942--
a very handsome man as some of
you may know if you've seen him
and capable of great
subtlety as an actor.
This may help to explain why
he was such a great director
of nonprofessional actors,
because he knew intuitively
I think, how to bring
out the performance
from someone who was not trained
in performing, in acting.
He begins to direct
in 1940 and makes
a series of moments in
interesting but forgettable
films I suppose.
His first really significant
film from one angle
anyway, especially if we're
interested in the development
of neorealism, is a film he
makes in 1942, co-screenwriter
Cesare Zavattini, it's entitled
The Children Are Watching Us.
It's-- I've seen the film.
It's not a great film.
But it's an interesting film.
And there are some
remarkable moments it.
The title tells you something
about the neorealist commitment
to focus on the under
privileged and the dis-empowered
in society.
Many neorealist films
focused directly on children.
And The Children Are
Watching Us is one such film.
And it almost announces
the idea that children
are among the victims of society
because they are subjected
not only to all the political
and social authorities
of the society, but
also to the arbitrary
authority of their own parents
and their own immediate family
environment.
So The Children Are
Watching Us announces
this interest in the
disenfranchised and especially
in children.
It's a film about the
breakup of a middle class
marriage mostly told through
the eyes of children.
So there are certain
things, certain behaviors
on the part of the adults
are never fully explained
because you witness
and experience
the film through
not just the eyes
but through the perceptions
the understanding,
the sensibility of children
who are somewhat confused
about what they're seeing.
The film that established him
as an international figure
and established neorealism
as an international movement
was one that to De
Sica and Zavattini
collaborated on in 1946.
It was entitled Shoeshine.
I sometimes have been tempted to
show Shoeshine in this course,
even though it's a much less
perfect film than Bicycle
Thieves because in its own way,
it's so powerful and moving.
One of the most interesting
things about neorealism,
apart from the fact that
it was so short lived,
is how relevant the
films still feel today.
If you watched Shoeshine
or another of the films
that I've listed here
on Umberto D which
is about the problems
that people who have gone
into-- of the old, people
who are retired, pensioners,
and the problems they face when
there is horrific inflation.
De Sica dedicated the
film to his father.
It's about an old man
who was very proud.
He used to be-- he
dresses very well.
But he's tremendously isolated.
He's terribly poor.
He's almost reduced to begging
in the course of the film.
There's even a moment
near the end of the film
where he contemplates and
then pulls back from suicide.
But watching that
film today, it feels
much less dated
than some films that
are much later than-- were
produced 10, 15, 20, 25
years after it because
the theme is so relevant.
Because we know that
in society today there
are so many-- in all
of a Western societies
but especially in
the United States--
there are pensioners who
can't make in ends meet.
The same thing is true,
I think, in some degree
of the role of the fate of
children in modern society.
So Shoeshine, although it has
a very melodramatic and violent
ending, it's an
immensely powerful film.
Essentially it's a story about
two boys, two Roman street
urchins who are taking
advantage of in some sense
by their own relatives who are
trafficking in black market
goods.
It's set in the same moment
at the end of the war.
In fact, the film opens
with these urchins
trying to make a living
as shoeshine boys.
That's why where the
title comes from.
And these shoeshine boys are
wandering the streets of Rome,
going up to American soldiers
who are dominating the streets,
it's still an occupied
city, asking soldiers
if they want shoe shines.
The children are
unbelievable victims.
They're very close friends.
They end up buying a racehorse,
a broken down old racehorse
that can't race anymore and
they stable it someplace.
They are very excited about
their possession of this horse.
There's some early
scenes in which
you see them riding on the
horse with tremendous joy
and so forth.
But of course this is the dawn
before the miserable night.
Because what then
happens is the kids
are taken advantage of by one
their-- by a close relative.
They're involved in
black market activities.
The adults use the
children because they
know that children are
less vulnerable than they
would be if they're caught.
The children are caught.
They're sent to reform school.
Most of the film takes
place in the reform school.
You see these two bright-eyed,
beautiful young children,
maybe 10 years old, who are the
fastest and closest of friends
when they go into jail,
slowly breaking down.
You see their humanity
being beaten out of them
by the conditions in the
reform-- in the children's
prison.
It's a terrible
disturbing film in part
because you could see that
the people who are running
the prison actually mean well.
They're not vicious, evil people
who want to harm children.
The system seems designed simply
to cause more harm than good
and to destroy the
vitality and optimism.
And when I say the film
ends melodramatically,
one child strikes out at
his erstwhile best friend
and knocks him down
a bank and he dies.
So he in effect accidentally
murders a person who
had been his dearest friend.
I think it's a
failure in the film.
I think that you didn't need
the murder for the meanings
of the film to be available.
I think that De Sica
learned something from that.
When you watch the ending
of the Bicycle Thief,
one of the things I
hope you'll ask yourself
is why is it so
apparently undramatic?
And why does that
undramatic ending
in the end seems so profound,
so moving, so meaningful?
It's as if De Sica sort
of learned his lesson.
It's as if he drove his
point home too heavily
at the end of Shoeshine.
He realized that to have
a truly organic text that
did what Bazin wants text
to do, reflect the unique
the unique ambiguity
of every experience.
The ending of the
Bicycle Thieves
does that much more effectively
as I hope you'll watch
for when you you're
watching the film.
Shoeshine made a
tremendous impact
and it won the first
of four Academy Awards
that De Sica won
as best director.
This was for the best foreign
film of the year in 1946
and it put new
realism on the map.
Then two years later
Zavattini and De Sica
followed with what I suppose we
could call their masterpiece,
Bicycle Thieves.
I want to say that this is not
a complete-- remotely complete
list of De Sica's films.
I've just listed
some highlights here
because I wanted to give
you a sense of his work.
I mentioned Umberto D already,
the last neorealist film
according to many people,
and a very moving one
about an old pensioner.
The film Two Women
stars Sophia Loren,
one of the great sort of
pulchritudinous Italian movie
stars of the '50s and '60s.
It got a lot of attention.
There were many other
interesting films that he made.
But one of his great triumphs
was the very last we made.
That's what I want
to mention it.
Zavattini returned to do
an uncredited coscreenplay
work on Finzi-Continis and
you can feel Zavattini's hand
in many moments in the film.
It's an adaptation of a novel.
As some of you may know,
it's really a Holocaust film.
It's about the buildup
to the Holocaust.
The Finzi-Continis are
very wealthy Italian Jews.
The story is about a poor
young Jewish scholar who is,
because of the
anti-Jewish laws that
are developing in
fascist Italy, is barred
from using the public library.
He's a very gifted
young scholar.
He's in his early '20s.
So he finds out that this very
wealthy aristocratic family,
also Jewish, the Finzi-Continis
have a magnificent library.
The Finzi-Continis open
their library to him
since he's barred from going
into the public library.
Of course what happens is,
you might guess this too,
it's a wonderful novel although
the film is even more beautiful
I think.
He falls in love with the
Finzi-Continis' daughter.
Right, so it's a class issue.
The poor boy, rich girl.
So the foreground of the film
is this cross class romance.
But in the background
of the film
it's something like cabaret but
not as dramatic, not as overt.
Because what's going on in
the background of the film
is the growth of fascism.
The end of the film ends with
many of the characters we've
gotten to know very well, both
young and old, all of them
Jews, some very
aristocratic and some
at the bottom of the
social hierarchy,
all being herded together
being ready to be shipped off
to the camps.
You don't actually go-- the
final scenes of the film
have them in the railroad
station being prepared
for their final journey.
The film is also full of comedy,
just as some of the passages
that I showed you in clips
from this afternoon mix comedy
with socially serious themes.
This is even truer of The
Garden of the Finzi-Continis
One of the reasons I like
the film so much is that it's
a return to the energies and the
moral passion that had marked
De Sica's earlier career.
And I think that
my own feeling is
the The Garden of
the Finzi-Continis
is one of the great
European films.
It certainly would be
on my list of the best
15 or 20 European
films of the sound era.
I think many of you would find
it very instructive and moving.
But I think especially
so after you
saw some of the truly neorealist
films, the early neorealist
films.
One can't really call The
Garden of the Finzi-Continis
a neorealist film although it
has many elements in common
with those earlier texts.
So De Sica was a remarkable
man, a significant actor,
a great director.
He directed 25
films in his career,
won four Oscars for
best foreign film.
He acted in more than
150 films, mostly
light, comic social
matters kind of roles.
But there's one exception
I perhaps should mention.
Playing in a film
for his friend,
Roberto Rossellini in 1959,
Rossellini's greatest film,
a film called General Della
Rovere, De Sica plays the lead
and it's probably his most
memorable performance.
It's a very, very
subtle and good film
about political
ambiguities and conflicts
of loyalty, human frailty,
and human inadequacies
in a way that's characteristic
of the best neorealist work.
So those are all films
I recommend or urge you
to consider watching
in your leisure time.
Let me say a few words
now about Bicycle Thieves.
I've already implied
or actually said
a part of what I want to say so
what I think I can be briefer
than I had originally planned.
Let me remind you again
about the structure.
I mentioned to you that
the structure of the film
is elegantly simple, that
the amount of time the passes
is very compressed.
And that's helpful because
the time compression
makes you aware of the
urgency of the quest
that the father and the son
are engaged in when they're
searching for the bicycle.
So one way-- and as the story
unfolds, a number of things
begin to happen.
The quest for the bicycle
becomes a kind of Odyssey
in which several things happen.
One is the film takes you
on an exploration of Rome.
It's like one of the
great city films.
It visits the city.
It explores the city.
You see different--
it's not just that you
see police stations and
religious institutions
and the catacombs
underneath the city.
Where the unions
meet, and where Ricci
first goes to get help from
Union members who promised him
that they'll find his
bike, very easily,
and they give him a plan
and he's very excited
and then the next
morning when they
follow the instructions of the
union, the boss doesn't help.
So the unions are breaking down
as well as the church, as well
as certain kinds of welfare
organizations in the state
and so on.
So one thing the film becomes
then is a kind of travelogue,
a kind of exploration
of the city,
the city's geography as well as
the city's make up in some way.
You go into different
neighborhoods
and you hear-- I
think Italians can
pick up the different
neighborhoods
speech patterns in
the film, at least
I've been told this
made by native Italians.
So it's a kind of
travelogue in one sense.
It explores this place.
And part of the
exploration of course
involves certain
ancillary or other themes
that are organically linked
to the story of going
through the city
looking for the bicycle.
One of course is
what we might call
the social themes of the film.
Because as the
protagonists make their way
through the city searching for
the bicycle what you encounter
are little vignettes
that tell you something
about the social hierarchies of
the society, about the efficacy
or in efficacy of
its institutions.
I won't go into
great detail here.
I hope you'll draw
your own conclusions
and name some of the
specific examples that
reinforce this general idea.
But I do want to
mention at least
one moment in this Odyssey.
One of the most dramatic
and disturbingly comic
moments in the film occurs
when Ricci and his son
actually think they've
seen the thief.
They think they recognize
him and they follow him.
And they get to
essentially a mission
where relatively well-off,
self-satisfied Christians
are serving meals to the
indigent and the poor, right?
Ricci gets into this institution
not because he sort of wants
the meal or because he
needs the religious uplift
but because he's
chasing his thief.
And he finds once he's in
there that he can't get.
It turns out that in
this institution that
not only do the poor have
to pay for their meal
by agreeing to all kinds of
religious behaviors, prayers,
and other kinds of things.
But they're also locked
into the building.
They're not allowed
eat, they're not
allowed to leave at least
until they finish eating.
Maybe they're not
allowed to leave
until they can be checked
to make sure they're not
stealing the soup bowls.
But in any case, it's a
very interesting moment
because you can see
that even the people who
would intend to
do well in society
often do more harm than good.
And of course the
implication is that
the traditional
religious institutions
and traditional
religious arrangements
are not sufficient
to take care of
or adequately to respect the
difficulties of the poor.
That's just one such moment.
There are number of others.
In fact there is
one other moment
I should mention as
a kind of contrast.
I've said that we see
many instances in which we
understand that the larger
institutions of society
like the police or the religious
system or the union system
are breaking down or not
really helping people.
But I will but I've
also said that there
are some other sort
of unofficial, and
non-institutionalized sources
of solidarity and comfort
that emerge in the
course of the film
and I hope you'll watch for
them and think about what
their significance is.
But there's one moment which
complicates this argument
because we can see the social
institutions of society not
actually functioning
effectively but at least showing
some compassion.
It's an astonishingly
vivid, meaningful moment
in the film, another one
of these moments so full
of multiplicity that the
meanings are so deeply embedded
in what you dramatically see
that sometimes you don't even
step back to generalize on the
meaning of what you've seen.
This is a scene very
early in the film
where Ricci actually goes
to retrieve his bicycle.
His wife has figured out a way--
basically what she figures out
is they sell her dowry.
She has a couple of
fancy silk sheets.
They take them to the hockshop,
and they pawn the sheets
in order to get enough money
to get the bicycle out of hock.
It means they're
going to be sleeping
on mattresses and but so what,
this is more important right?
You see Ricci and his wife go to
the pawn shop which is clearly
run by the state.
Is not like a
private pawn-- it's
obviously a city
institution of some kind.
And they bring the linen up to
the guy and he looks at them
and he says, OK, I'll
give you this much money.
And they need a little
bit more because they
need to get the bike out of hock
so they ask him for more money.
And he looks at it, he says,
oh, it's not really worth it
but, OK.
And it's an act of
generosity on his part
because he didn't have to do it.
He gives them just enough money
for this stuff so that they
can get his bike out of hock.
And then, completely silent, you
see him pick this material up,
this pawned bedding,
this pawned linen,
and he turns around-- I think
he does-- he may give it
to another character.
I haven't looked at
this scene a year or two
so I don't remember the exact--
you'll recognize the scene.
I think it's the same man
who does it or he may give it
to someone else.
The material-- the three or
four sheets that are involved
are taken by someone.
He walks to the back
of a room, and he
begins to climb a ladder.
As he climbs you realize that
what he's climbing up is-- he's
climbing a ladder
which is leaning
against a series of shelves
that seem to go on endlessly.
They seem to be in an
auditorium the size
of the city of Pittsburgh.
And they go up endlessly
high and every single shelf,
every single inch of
space on the shelf
is filled with bedding as
if the entire city of Rome
has pawned its bedding,
as if everybody in Rome
is sleeping on mattresses.
Now the film never makes
a comment about this.
No one in the film
says anything about it.
But it's an unbelievably
resonant and rich moment.
And it's also-- it
does further the sort
of social themes of the film.
But it occurs in a moment
in which you will also
see the pawn broker showing
a moment of compassion
and generosity.
And if you did not
show that generosity
they wouldn't have been
able to get the bicycle.
So it's a complicated moment.
But if all this linen
has been pawned,
there's some question
about whether or not
the city services are doing
much good for anybody.
The city's in obvious
trouble if nobody
has any bed linen any longer.
The implication is this is
an unbelievably impoverished
and damaged environment.
But it's done in such a quiet
way there's even something
almost comic about
the sense you have
of the endless number
of these things.
Even the idea that you have to
distinguish one from the other
seems from our vantage
point a bit silly,
even though each one
has a ticket on it,
each one belongs to
an individual family.
So watch for that moment.
It has some of that ambiguity
that Bazin talks about.
So the structure of the
film is organic in the sense
that nothing that
happens in the film
doesn't seem to
arise naturally out
of the needs of the characters.
We have to find our new bike.
And in the course of their
travels other things happen.
The boy has to pee,
they get hungry.
They have to eat.
Or sometimes it rains, they
have to get out of the rain.
Right?
And that becomes part
of the ongoing sort
of organic development
of the story.
You never once feel,
I think, in this film
that any event has been
imposed from the outside.
Every event seems
to arise naturally
out of the circumstances and
nature of the characters.
And that's why I
call it organic.
It's a deeply organic way of
thinking about the material.
But it's organic in
another way too course
because it's deeply coherent.
When you finally finished
the film, when you step back,
you say, OK, yes the
film slowed down here.
And yes, the film seemed
to generate what Thorburn
calls a counter plot here.
Nonetheless, taken
as a whole, there's
a profound moral and
thematic coherence
in this organically fluid movie.
So the structure of the
film is part of its essence.
And although I haven't
put this on the outline
because we've talked about
this so often already,
pay attention to the Renoir-ish
type camera behavior.
The film's visual style
is like Jean Renoir's.
There's a kind of
elegant restlessness
to the camera that's very much a
part of what the film achieves.
So in talking about
the social themes
all I meant to
call your attention
to was the extent to which
in a variety of ways,
the film calls attention
to the miserably endangered
circumstances of ordinary
people in this broken down, war
torn environment.
It also looks to those, or seems
to find without even looking,
to dramatize or reveal
those sources of support
and sustenance that get
us through bad times.
As you're watching the
ending of the film,
ask yourself what
these things mean.
I won't actually
tell you whether he
recovers the bike or not, let
you see that for yourself.
But ask yourself, whether
or not he recovers the bike,
would it have made
any difference?
Does it matter given what
the film is finally saying
to us in those final images?
Well, character.
This is one of the great
films about character,
I think, especially
about the relation
between the father of the son.
They're at the very
center of the film.
I've already said in a way that
this Odyssey that they go on
is a travelogue.
It teaches us about
the geography,
social circumstances, social
arrangements, and class system
and institutional
systems of Rome.
It does that.
But it's also an Odyssey in
which the father of the son
get to know each other in
a deeper and in many ways,
much more disturbing
way than has ever
happened to them before.
The most poignant and terrible
thing about this film in fact,
is that the Odyssey
I've been describing
through Rome with
his son, by Ricci,
is also an initiation story,
a story about growing up.
But what happens to
Ricci's son in this film
doesn't happen to most young
boys until they're much older.
And it happens gradually,
not all at once.
But what Ricci's son discovers
in the course of this day
are his father's flaws.
He discovers things
about his father
that no boy really wants
to know even if he's 67
years old like your professor.
And he discovers these things
about his father in the most
stressful circumstances.
His father's violent
toward him, his father
is indifferent toward him.
Then there are moments
when after his father feels
terrible anxiety and
grief over the way
he's treated him where his
father tries to make up
with him and you can see the boy
not wanting to let them do it.
It's unbelievably rich.
And I don't think anyone
who pays attention to this
will fail to recognize the
interactions between the father
and son as unbelievably
true, marvelously
accurate to the way in
which loving parents
and loving children often
interact with each other.
Because they have many moments
where they're really not
happy with each other at all.
What the boy discovers
about his father
are some things
that no child ever
wants to know about his father.
Not just that he's flawed, but
he's deeply, deeply flawed,
that he's capable of
really terrible behavior.
And the boy is-- something
happens in this Odyssey.
It's one of the subtlest
things about the film.
The basic relations between
fathers and sons are reversed.
We find that the son,
this little child,
is twice in the film in
the position of having
to rescue his father.
I'm simplify certain
things because I don't
want to give away the plot.
But you'll see how this
works out in the film.
I mean there are two moments
in the film in which Ricci
fate would be far more dire
than it is because of his son's
presence.
His son, in a sense,
is his Savior.
The fathers are supposed
to protect their sons
not the reverse.
Part of the meaning
of this adventure
is that Ricci has been reduced
to such a miserable level that
even has to rely on his son's
help in order to get by.
Both of them, the father and
son experience this reversal.
So it's a psychologically
traumatic and deeply moving
experience.
Although don't misunderstand.
I'm not suggesting
that the child doesn't
come to terms-- he does come
to terms with what he learns.
I think is quite remarkable.
I mean I would have
had trouble with what
that boy comes to
terms with as an adult
but he does it as a child.
But I think of course it's
also believable as you'll see.
So the film is
profound and serious
about the social circumstances
of postwar Italy.
Is profound and serious
about the indifference
of certain kinds of
institutional arrangements
to the real miseries
of human experience.
And it is a powerful and deep
exploration of human character
and especially,
centrally, the relation
between Ricci and his son.
The relation between
fathers and sons--
becomes a kind of one of the
great parables of the relations
between adults and children.
It's one of the great father
and son stories of all time.
Let me conclude by
saying a couple of words
about the title.
I mean there's much more in the
film I wish I can talk about.
But by this time in
the course if you
can't get this stuff yourself,
I haven't done my job.
I hope all of you are watching
films much more attentively
and carefully than
you had before.
I hope that your
enjoyment has been
increased rather than
decreased by what
you've learned in this course.
Let the Bicycle Thief be a test.
Because in many ways it's
not kind of film most of you
guys would go out to watch.
First of all it's
in black and white.
Second it's more
than 50 years old.
But I think you'll
I think you'll
recognize that it hasn't
aged, that the film is
as compelling now as it was
when it was-- maybe even more
compelling now than
when it was made
because some of the political
turmoil has disappeared.
There's no longer the
taint of fascism hanging
over Italian
artistic productions
as they were at
the end of the war.
There's a historical
sense of the importance
of this movement.
So maybe we can look at these
neorealist films with a more
objective eye than the
original audiences could.
In any case the title
is an interesting one.
When it was first
translated into English,
and in fact it's
still widely known,
you might have noticed a
slips of the tongue on my part
where I started to call
it the Bicycle Thief.
And the reason is, it's
still often called that.
When it was originally
brought into the United States
and translated both
in Great Britain
and in the United States, it
was called The Bicycle Thief.
Now the Italian
is in the plural.
It's Ladri di Bicilette.
Thieves of the bicycle would
be the literal translation.
Right now the question
is why the plural?
I think you could imagine the
answer just from that opening
sequence that I showed
you this afternoon.
Why would it be plural?
Why would the title be plural?
One of the reasons is from
the very opening sequence,
we see that everybody--
that the bicycle
is a very ambiguous and
complicated symbol in the film.
Symbol is a bad
word because it's
such an actuality that
it seems pretentious
to call it a symbol.
You see hundreds
of maybe thousands
of bicycles in the film.
That's part of what makes
Ricci's loss of the bicycle so
poignant.
You have the sense as he's
walking around the city,
oh my God, everybody
has a bicycle.
There are 10 million
bicycles in this city.
Poor Ricci can't
find one, can find--
there's something horrific about
the idea that an item so common
could still for Ricci you be
so precious, as to constitute
his livelihood or threaten
against his livelihood
if he can't find the bicycle.
You can guess now based
on what I've already
said one reason for why
the title is plural.
Why?
As Ricci's walking around
looking for his bicycle,
walking through a
city full of hundreds
and thousands of bicycles,
what might he think?
What might you think if you
needed the bicycle desperately?
Why not pinch one?
Why not thieve?
So one of the reasons
that the title is plural
is that Ricci is
one of the thieves.
I'm only suggesting that
he's a thief by sort
of psychological inclination.
He looks lovingly--
as you'll see,
the plot makes this
even more explicit.
I don't want to
give away the plot.
I will.
He actually does in a
certain sense become a thief.
But long before he
becomes a literal thief
and actually puts his hands
on someone else's bicycle,
you and I might even think
some people in the audience
may get the idea
before Ricci does.
When you're watching this
guy, so terrible, looking
every place for his bicycle,
he's surrounded by bicycles,
sees inundated by bicycles.
After he recovers the bicycle,
before he goes to work,
on his wife asks him to take
into a special location.
She wants to thank someone.
It turns out, that he had--
and they get on the bike,
she rides behind him and
he rides over on the bike.
And he waits outside this
place while his wife goes up.
His wife is taking a long time.
So he leans his bike
against the wall.
He starts to go up the stairs.
He looks, and sees his bike is
vulnerable so he walks down,
he finds a kid, gives the kid,
I think he gives the kid a coin,
and tells the kid
to guard the bike.
And then he starts walking
up the stairs again.
This is very early in the film.
And think how clever this is.
You're aware of how vulnerable
the bike is from that moment.
This is a day before
it's stolen, right?
You're aware of how precious
is and as he ascends
the stairs you
actually become afraid
that his bicycle
might be stolen.
So one of the reasons
the title is ambiguous
is I think in the end, the
title encompasses not just
the thief who
steals Ricci's bike
and not just Ricci himself
who contemplates becoming
a thief in his desperation, but
also the audience which becomes
complicit Ricci's impulse
to criminality because we
are ourselves think God,
steal a goddamn bike.
Take the bike.
Stop worrying about it.
Get it.
Get away.
There's a bike you could take.
And I think anyone
watching the film
has this feeling after
a relatively short time
so that we are bicycle
thieves as well.
So part of the subtlety
of the title-- and you'll
see as the film works itself
out, I've already implied this.
When they finally catch up
the thief, alleged thief,
the guy they think
is the thief, he
turns out to be an even
more miserable specimen
than poor Ricci.
He's an epileptic.
He's out of work.
He has to be protected
by this community.
His mother's very
protective of him.
There's some modest minor
possibility that he's acting,
that he's faking
his mental problems
and maybe faking everything.
But I don't think so.
You could judge yourself
whether what is in any case,
any case surely true, is that
the neighborhood coalesces
around him because
Ricci and his son
are strangers and
are attacking someone
from their neighborhood.
So when this happens, one
of the things you'll feel
is not just that
the thief Ricci was
going after deserves
some sympathy too.
You begin to feel some sense
that his difficulties are-- not
that you excuse his thievery--
but you understand it
in a deep and
generous way I think.
That complicates your sense
of who the thieves are
and what thieves are like.
And then you've come
to recognize that Ricci
is a potential thief.
And you care about Ricci.
You see what a loving father
he is, how desperate he
is to take care of his family.
So you sympathize with him.
And then, you realize
if you've been thinking
about it, that of
course you've been
covering bicycles yourself.
So the audience
and the real thief
and Ricci the would-be thief
are all implicated together
as if what he's saying is
that our common humanity is
what bicycle thieves suggest.
And that's one of the
reasons that the title
needs to be plural
because the film is not
about a single bicycle thief.
It's about the bicycle
thief in all of us.
Enjoy the film.